this is a production of Cornell
University
and thanks Kevin for inviting me really
had a number of great talks this morning
with people already so the title my talk
is about the role of the Andes in the
tropical plant diversification and after
I sent that title I realized that I've
only spent about six months working on
this topic and so what you'll see is a
lot about lowland rainforest
diversification and then the latter part
focused more exclusively on the Andes
which which is a sort of more recent
development and as Kevin mentioned I'm
very interested in tropical forest
biomes this graphic will probably
explain why this shows the global
distribution of tree diversity and we
have three main biomes here we have our
boreal forests represented in blue we
have our temperate zone forests in red
and we have our tropical forests in
green and each of these boxes represents
the number of species of trees in each
of these regions and this these numbers
on the side indicate the total tally so
you can see 161 species about 1600
species here and then 43,000 species in
the tropical realm so it's a huge
diversity in global terms in tropical
forests and then when you think not at
the regional or continental scale but at
a very local scale there are many
species that are packed into very small
areas in tropical forests so in this
forest in the in Ecuador al Gentry noted
that there were 300 tree species all
above 10 centimeters in diameter in a
single hectare of forest so this has
been a topic that's been interesting to
biologists for over a century there are
two main ways to approach this question
of why is there so much tropical
diversity one is through an ecological
approach which would focus on why there
are so many species coexisting in small
areas that be focused on competition or
bevery the other way approach would be
look at the evolutionary history of
those
for us and that that's sort of the main
area that my lab is interested in
so the overall talk outline I'm going to
talk a bit about the history of the
tropical forest biome I'm going to talk
more exclusively about rainforests and
particularly work that I've done on the
thyroid geography of widespread
rainforest trees and then finally I'm
going to talk about ambient plant
diversification and its role in sort of
creating all of this diversity so if we
think about tropical forests history we
have to go back to Alfred Russel Wallace
and he noticed you know way back in the
nineteenth century
that one reason why tropical forests
probably had so much diversity is
because they've been so stable as a
biome not only do they not have these
very bitter winters and you know
dormancy that's required of plants and
animals but also over geological time
periods they've been much more stable so
they haven't been recently wiped out by
glacial glacial activity and so if we
think about the geological history of
tropical forests I want to just prevent
present a little overview this will take
us back sort of starting at the KT
boundary Kate Reed QT boundary is where
we at least have fossil records we know
we had forests that are similar to
modern forests so at the KT boundary and
beyond in the paleo gene we have here is
our representative of tropical forests
and since we're already outside of the
tropical region we have to give another
name for these forests this is what we
call mega thermal for us so these are
forests that cannot endure any kind of
freezing their their warmth loving so
the mega thermal forests extended all
the way up into New York Michigan during
the peléan so there's a much greater
expansion of forests from 65 to 24
million years ago and this because the
earth was much warmer and there was less
of a latitudinal gradient and changes in
temperature and we know that from fossil
records in Colombia that tropical
forests were highly diverse
even in this very early stage of
rainforest development as diverse
probably as today at least at the
generic level level of genrih if we look
at the Neogene sort of the past 24
million years until the beginning of the
ice ages we had many important
developments forests the mega thermal
forests or shrank and contracted into
the equatorial regions so now they're
mostly within this tropical area but we
see a lot of developments geologically
we see the the emergence of the Isthmus
of Panama which is a land bridge that
connects South America and North America
allowing for the great American biotic
interchange we see the development of
the Andes Mountains during this period
in time and so this is important in
terms of the development of sort of
South American landscapes and then
finally the quaternary the past 2.6
million years this is a period marked by
major climatic fluctuations glacial
interglacial periods and when there were
glacial periods that's when the forests
shrank the most and they're 65 million
year history it's a much smaller extent
than they were in the past 65 million
years in this led to the development of
Pleistocene refuge hypothesis which
posited that the contraction of these
rainforests would have led to an
accelerated rate of speciation during
the past 2.6 million years and so this
is the overall view if we look back 65
million years to present this is these
are proxies for temperature global mean
temperature and this represents a higher
temperature so the the peak temperature
was a sort of paleocene-eocene boundary
and then our global temperatures have
got increasingly cool over the Cenozoic
and now they're they're moving back up
into these areas but the area but the
temperatures that are predicted for the
year 2100 are similar to some of the
temperatures that we see here in this
Neogene time frame and they're even
warmer earlier in
history one thing that we discovered in
just looking at the the phylogeny z' of
in the bio Geographic history of the
major families that comprise rainforests
if there's been a lot of movement across
continents of rainforest lineages so
even though we think of South America as
being isolated for tens of millions of
years there's actually been dispersal
events that have been significant and
then that have resulted in the invasions
of continental by Otis very quick
depiction of continental drift as about
65 million years worth of movement and
at 3 million years ago
we have panama connecting North America
and so we have this great American
biotic interchange but at many points
throughout the past 65 million years
there have been migration events while
South America was an island continent
including from these mega thermal
forests that were in North America and
Europe which we call the boreal tropics
from Asian forests from Africa and Toby
Pennington and I tried to quantify the
impact of this migration and we looked
at the Yasuni forest inventory plot
versus 25 Hector's has 1,100 species and
we estimated that 30% of the tree
species and about 30% of the biomass in
the actual stem counts came from
immigrant lineages so it's a very
important impact of long-distance
dispersal
so this led to there are two major ideas
when I was a graduate student that I had
thought about about tropics and the wine
mid is associated with Alfred Russel
Wallace is that the tropics are that
kind of Museum of biological diversity
because of the stability of this biome
and their long history and being even
more expansive than they are today
species would be able to accumulate over
time without much of an extinction rate
and so under this model you'd expect to
have fairly old lineages that go all the
way back through the Cenozoic but under
a cradle model this is where these other
ideas about you know the impact of
potential Pleistocene refugee are coming
into play or maybe more recent
geological developments driving
speciation under those models the
tropics may be an area of active
speciation with high extinction rates
where you would expect most of the
diversity to be more recent in origin
and that's kind of broadly called a
cradle model and we can represent that
if I would genetically under a museum
model if we think back through the
Cenozoic from the present back to the KT
boundary of the KPG boundary under a
museum model we'd expect common
ancestors of our species in general to
sort of coalesce going way back through
the past 65 million years whereas under
a cradle model we expect very small
branch lengths and more recent
diversification
an example of the the cradle model was
founded in the genus Inga
so Inga is a tree genus about 300 tree
species only found in near tropical
forests most of the species are widely
distributed and morphologically very
distinctive from one another and Toby
Pennington James Richardson and
colleagues tried to work out a phylogeny
and found that they couldn't work out
the phylogeny there was not enough
phylogenetic resolution not enough
genetic divergence among the species and
they placed the the genus phylogeny into
the broader lady imply largely an
estimated that the genus arose six to
ten million years ago with 2/3 of the
species originating during quaternary
which was consistent with sort of a
Pleistocene refuge hypothesis and they
suggested that you know this is this may
be the case with most Amazon tree
species that most Amazon trees may
actually be very recent in origin so my
my supervisor postdoc collaborated at
the time and I were invited to write a
prospective piece in science for this
article and it just didn't strike us as
being very realistic and the reason
being is that when we think about the
forests and we were familiar with in
barro Colorado Island and Yasuni there's
a very deep taxonomic structure so not
only are there lots of species but at
higher levels of the level of genus and
families there's also a lot of higher
level taxonomic diversity so that for
example in this Yasuni forest with our
eleven hundred tree species in a 25
hectare plot there are three hundred and
thirty three genera and eighty-one
families of plants represented and so we
can look at the distributions of how
many species there are per genus on the
average so about 160 of those Jenna are
represented by a single species and many
of those general are in fact monotypic
there are many gener that only have a
single or one or two or three or four
species their species poor and so Inga
is actually the extreme stream outlier
it's a genus that has 43 species
in this forest plot so in this regard
anger was something of an outlier and so
at the time I was doing five Geographic
work and I became interested in
particular in widespread widely
distributed species that were found in
both in Central America and in South
America and also thinking about the age
structure of some of these species poor
genore and so my first work was focused
on symphony globular fora this is a
species in the clue za CV it's very
distinctive in rainforests it's
something that I as a graduate student I
saw it frequently in Manaus Brazil as a
postdoc I saw it in Panama when I
visited in French Guiana I saw it in
forest plots there I saw it in Yasuni
everywhere I traveled I saw it and in
interestingly enough it's also very
common in widespread in Africa it has a
very distinctive morphology which is
very important because when there's a
thousand trees in the forest you want to
be able to identify your species no
matter what forest you're in so I could
always identify it to a combination of
characters these aerial buttress is
aerial roots and a sort of bright orange
latex very distinctive globular flower
and another really useful point about
symphonia there's only one species of
symphonia found in the Neotropics and it
has a very distinctive pollen type and
the pollen has been used extensively by
the oil industry first orthography so if
they want to find a character that
indicates that there's rainforest in a
particular region or find the age of a
particular site they often look for
symphonia pollen so we have actually
have a pretty good record of the fossil
distribution of symphonia relative to
other rainforest trees
so at the time they were that I was
doing this study there were no thyroid
Geographic studies of tropical plants
tropical trees and one of the things
that drew me to Philo geography was was
traveling and so I was able to visit a
lot of these sites visit forests that I
hadn't seen before collect symphonia and
then I relied on herbarium material to
fill in the gaps that or bury material
from Africa and from other locations and
I use standard plant systematic markers
I TS chloroplast DNA not knowing that
these would even be variable within this
species so this is a these show the
sites that I visited and this is
actually based on I TS internal
transcribed spacer sequence and each of
these colors represents a distinct
haplotype or sequence and these these
circles sort of show the clustering of
where the related haplotypes occurred so
there's an Amazonian group a an area
west of the Andes up through Central
America it's highly diverse but
constitutes a clade a West Indian clade
and then this this African group and
this shows the fossil history so
simfonia fossil pollen first occurs
about 45 million years ago off the coast
of Nigeria so very old as a genus at
least the first Nia tropical records are
off the coast of Brazil and in the
Maracaibo basin in Venezuela at about 15
million years ago and then in Central
America we have the first fossils
appearing about 8 million years ago so
just based on that fossil information
alone we can infer that there had been
some oceanic dispersal event that led to
the establishment of symphony in the
Amazon basin sometime in the Maya scene
because the West Indies have always been
Islands and this is a very distinctive
genetic group this would have had to
have derived either from South America
or from
Africa and in there there had to have
been assuming that there was no Isthmus
of Panama eight million years ago there
had been dispersal from South America
and Central America by oceanic currents
this is a phylogenetic reconstruction of
symphonia and all the other species of
Symphonia besides symphonia globular are
found in madagascar they're about 20
species of symphonia in madagascar and
then one species everywhere else these
are the Madagascar Madagascan species
and these are the clades within West
Africa and then sister to this
neotropical group so there's a clade
that's just sort of in the Amazon region
and Guiana Shield and then one that's in
the trans Andes I used the 15 million
year fossils to sort of calibrate this
clade and that gave me you know
approximately seven million years of the
age of the Central American group which
is consistent with the fossil record so
the thing to note about this is we have
this very high level of phylogenetic
resolution and phylogenetic depth within
a single widespread species and the
species is actually older than the
entire genus of inga which has 300
species it's a it's a genius that it
co-occurs with in just about every
forest but it's a very old species and
when I published this work the editor of
the journal said well this is really a
living fossil you know you should sort
of sell it as a living fossil it's very
unusual just unchanged morphologically
for such a long period at a time the
other interesting thing was what it
revealed about oceanic dispersal leading
to sort of the assembly patterns of
these of these forests so obviously I
had this great result and I wanted to
see what I could learn about other
widespread species so the next one that
I looked at was ceiba pentandra now
ceiba you might be familiar with is the
kapok tree it's one of the most enormous
trees that you'll find in the amazon
basin this is a selfie taken by Robin
Foster back in about 1966 on BCI and
Panama or Colorado Island
this tree just fell down last year
unfortunately this is called big tree
you can see it's got these huge buttress
roots and it's got these these little
seeds that are wrapped in sort of a
cotton a silk it's a very fast growing
guys up to two meters per year it sort
of establishes along riverbanks and the
largest ones are along the Solomons
River in the Amazon basin with
nutrient-rich areas a little bit natural
history I love natural history keeps me
going this is bat pollination of
symphonia taken but photo taken by a
colleague of mine in Brazil so what I
found with symphonia is a very different
pattern so using those same sets of
molecular markers this is another
haplotype map the bottom part shows the
chloroplast DNA so the chloroplast DNA
using the most variable chloroplast
region was entirely monomorphic in other
words no variation throughout Central
America amazon basin and africa
absolutely no DNA sequence variation
just one nucleotide variant in the west
coast of Ecuador and there were some IPS
haplotypes but showing no flower
geographic pattern whatsoever and it
turns out that the other species of
ceiba are located in the Amazon basin
there are several other species so the
species likely originated in South
America and it got through long-distance
dispersal probably the oceanic currents
arrived in Africa we know that it
arrived in Africa before pre-columbian
times because there are records of Arab
traders moving the species in the 10th
century into Asia so it naturally got
into Africa but over a very recent time
scale in very weak phyla geographic
structure and probably not a very old
species in general
so then I became well okay we have these
extreme cases we have one widespread
species that's very charismatic and well
known but a very recent in origin and we
have another one that is very ancient
and everywhere you go it shows deep
follow Geographic breaks and divergence
and so I wanted to understand more about
these patterns and I decided to focus
particularly on looking at the Andean
bear barrier and looking at populations
that were located on either side of the
Andes in northern South America and this
was fascinating to me I was in Ecuador
and I was reading the catalogue of the
vascular plants of Ecuador and I came
across a quote by Peter Raven and he
indicated that you know right when they
are tallying the plant diversity they
said that 30% of the plants found in
lowland rainforests of Ecuador are found
on both sides of the Andes and so that
that account that's about 1,400 species
so he said that about 30 percent of the
lowland flora has been around prior to
the uplift of the Andes in that mate
that means that a large portion of these
akia logical communities have been
really stable for several millions of
years because the Andes are several
million years old I was really
interested in this idea in thinking wow
there must be large components that are
very old in these rainforest communities
and this is a situation known as
vicariance when you have a widespread
population and then it's sort of broken
up when a barrier geographic barrier
rises in the middle of it
that's called vicariance so that
vicariance history would indicate that
these populations would have a median
age to be going back prior to the
Pleistocene and so we have our
northernmost Andes these are so the most
recent part of the Andes to form and in
Merida this would have been the final
barrier that would have been presented
and the uplift of Merida Andes is about
2.7 million years ago sort of right
between where the Neo G and the
quaternary are and so as a way to test
this I looked at estimated the ages of
the ancestors of these populations and
if they fell well within
Neogene period that would support Andean
vicariance if they are well my
quaternary that would indicate some kind
of dispersal to get around the Andes and
I just want to note that not only are
the Andes important as an elevational
barrier but also right beside the Andes
you have this really dry area be honest
and so any plant that is able to get
around the Andes is going to have to
deal in some way with drought you know
with drying dry habitats so I picked I
had 14 study species some of them were
dealt with in individual case studies
were sampled much more broadly but for
all the species I at least sampled in
Panama Western Ecuador in the eastern
Ecuador using these same sets of
molecular markers in that included ceiba
pentandra symphonia globular fora as
well as some other species that are
fairly well known like a Croma which is
the balsa wood producing tree Jacaranda
woman for its flowers and I also looked
at actually a student of mine Jordan
demos looked at some functional traits
associated with these trees so he looked
at drought tolerance through ecological
niche modeling we looked at where these
species were found some of them like
symphonia global ephra were only found
in the wettest forests true rainforest
whereas others were found in drier
forest areas they're found in seasonally
dry forests indicating they had more
drought tolerant abilities we also
looked at some other characters
functional trades so the results were
that nine out of the 14 species had a
Nia gene aged population structure so
they had population histories that went
back before three million years ago none
of these species had much morphological
variation despite these deep temporal
divergences among these populations and
we also noticed that there was this
association the species that did manage
to
I'll get around the in the Andes during
the quaternary those tend to be the
drought tolerant species and now we're
currently looking at more species we
have 85 species all together that are
shared between the BCI and then in the
ass knee forests and we're using other
molecular markers particularly a rad
seek DNA to analyze these divergences
but this figure just gives you an idea
this goes back through there's ten
million year history and we can see
here's the age for our crossing and debt
and E and divergence of symphonia
globular fora myth not even the oldest
species you know there are several
species that have higher levels of
genetic divergence between the across
the Indian populations then symphonia
does there's this group particular down
here this is very old then we have a
couple species are sort of the Pliocene
Pleistocene boundary and then we have a
group that definitely seemed to have
their origin of quaternary or sort of
younger but you can see some of the
things that species like symphonia have
experienced they've experienced warmth
global warmth warmer temperatures than
are expected for the year 2100 with
global climate change they've
experienced the uplift of the Andes the
development of the Merida Andes the
closure of the Isthmus of Panama
these have been species have been part
of rainforest for all this period and
this just shows this sort of how the
drought tolerant and intolerant species
sort of segregate out so the drought you
know all the youngest species are
drought tolerant indicating that maybe
that have played a role in allowing them
to get around the Andes so the Andes is
really a filter sort of lets the drought
tolerant species through but it keeps
the rain forest specialists on either
side and separated
so this isn't Alfred Russel Wallace is
club this is mine and it's just to say
that a long side species like Ingo which
definitely do represent recent
diversification in kind of a cradle mode
there are many living fossil fossil
images many lineages that are just
hanging out in the rain forests for
millions of years without much notable
morphological or ecological divergence
okay so where do the Andes fit in we've
seen how they fit in as a barrier but
they actually contribute a whole lot
more to me a tropical plant diversity so
here we have our original photo and here
we have the the Andes so there are
estimated 45,000 plant species in the
Andes 44% of those are endemic to the
Andean region so that's a huge amount of
the overall contribution of neotropical
plant diversity this localized on the
Andes and there are many many important
linkages geologically between the Amazon
and the Andes and I've explored these a
lot recently in collaboration with
geologists who will dispute every point
that I bring up today but but for the
time being I find this a very reasonable
scenario this is a review paper by
Karina horn from back in 2010 and it
shows the Cenozoic development of the
Amazon basin even before there was an
Amazon River so at the very beginning of
the Cenozoic 65 233 million years ago
this is the Amazon drainage sort of
moved in this direction and it actually
flowed probably out through where the
Orinoco River is and you see that
there's not the Alpine habitat would be
in red so there's not much Montaigne
habitat at that point it's just slowly
developing
and so as the auntie's are uplifting
particularly these northern Andes
they're causing these drainage patterns
to shift and the causing to at one point
shift northward at one point developed a
large wetland system until finally they
forced the drainage to move eastward and
so we have the development of a modern
Amazon River at about ten million years
ago we have the continued rising up of
the Andes and as the Andes raised up all
of a sudden its changes the climate it
adds new precipitation there's a rain
shadow effect there's lots of moisture
now really available in this area and it
also changes global circulation patterns
of air as well and it also changing the
Amazon basin in a very important way by
adding nutrient-rich sediments over the
first time you know these are very
ancient crayons that are sandy and not
very nutrient-rich all the sudden you
have these new parent material rising up
in depositing all kinds of sediments
into this region so it's changing
ecosystem properties like like carbon
flux as well as well as promoting
different kind of ecological niche and
then finally over the quaternary we have
the development of jános this dry area
and then all the climate changes that
are associated with the ice ages
in terms of bio geographic processes
I've discussed a lot about how the Andes
work as a barrier and it's a barrier up
of 30% of the rainforest species in
Ecuador it acts as a corridor
particularly for temperate zone species
to actually move into this region in
northern South America and potentially
most of them are residing in this region
and specie ating when they get here some
of them actually do move into the
lowlands and of course it's acting as a
speciation pump or a cradle of
diversification certainly the Alpine
habitats have seen an incredible amount
of diversification but I think that with
these new sediments that were formed in
the slopes of the Andes I think that
also promoted some diversification and I
think that maybe where we have anga
playing out because inga has its center
of distribution as a genus i'm sort of
this slope of the Andes
and this is a great review paper by
Lewbert and Wiegand that came out
recently there have been a lot of
phylogenetic studies of claves in the
Andean region and made it a synthesis of
the of the studies and they tried to
place all the ones that had any kind of
age estimates associated with them into
context and they associated them with
different regions of the Andes so they
separate the Andes into a northern
region sort of a north-central and
central Andean region in the southern
Andes and these are progressively
younger as you move north southern Andes
being potentially the oldest part of the
Andes and if you kind of squint your
eyes and you know don't apply statistics
you can see that the southern Andes do
have quite a lot of older lineages with
ancestors to go back into the Maya scene
and for the northern Andy and clays
there actually are a lot that seem to
have their origin in the quaternary or
the or the Pliocene so it is you know
potentially possible that we'd be able
to sort of find this association with
the age of the mountain and the age of
the clades that are associated with them
so this is a project that that I
recently began participating in this
past year with a group of geologists and
we had funding from NSF from frontiers
of Earth system dynamics and the goal of
it they were geologists who are really
interested in the Amazon biodiversity
and how it was generated and they also
know a lot about Andean history and we
wanted to get together a group of people
that were experts in Andy and uplift
geomorphology paleoclimatology
contemporary climates ecosystem function
and they really wanted somebody that
could contribute in terms of the plant
phylogenetic history or fire geographic
history so we've been meeting together
regularly and talking about these
patterns and and some questions we have
like in the plant side are we want to
know like was the diversification that
we see in
clades was that because these plants
migrated into new habitat that was very
open and didn't exist before and they
just immediately start occupying these
novel habitats or as some people have
suggested is it because these habitats
are kind of like Islands so these
mountaintops are like islands so that
whenever you have climate change these
islands grow and sometimes coalesce and
then shrink back again and so this would
be a kind of Pleistocene refuge model
applied to the tops of the mountains so
we wanted nests or what are some of
those dry what is driving that
diversification and also what are the
major drivers of the diversification
apart from allopatric with respect to
echo logical niche important ecological
traits some people how gently suggested
that the ability to move into
hummingbird pollination opened up a lot
of ecological space for for high
elevation plants as well as genomic
evolution and then what is the
contribution of the Andean suit
associated species with lowland
rainforest diversity thinking about Inga
you know
- what extended this cradle of
diversification impact Amazonian flora
so we actually will be gathering our own
data
pretty soon starting this summer but
over the past few months what we've done
is we've gone into the literature and
we've done a meta-analysis of existing
studies and this is a in collaboration
with Steven Smith this is a way when you
get a gmail from him this is how his
face appears and anybody who knows him
knows that that's exactly what he looks
like and he's just like a beard and
black glasses and this is his
undergraduate student Carolyn he's been
actually getting to do all the work of
developing scripts to pull out DNA
sequences from GenBank analyzed in the
large scale and we've then these
diversification analyses that are based
on techniques that were developed by Dan
hrabowski who is actually a PhD student
here very recently at Laboratory of
Ornithology
any questions about this he'll be giving
a talk here in the Cornell in a couple
of weeks so please hold your questions
for him there's a lot of mathematical
magic that happens in there that but
what this shows is a phylogenetic tree
with sort of a heat map and it shows
when you have changes or significant
shifts in the rate of diversification
diversification being sort of the
speciation rate minus the extinction
rate and this is the net impact and so
here we have a fast rate of
diversification slowing down and then
showing a significant slowdown for
example in this clade here we have the
Andean clade this is the common ancestor
of the Andean group which is shown here
with this green dot and there's actually
no evidence for any change in the
diversification rate when this group
reaches the Andes this is the kind of
thing that we're looking at with this
data and blue being slow rate of
diversification yellow medium red is a
rapid rate so that that example that I
showed you there was barbarous you might
be familiar with Japanese Barbary which
is invasive in Michigan so when this
genus reached the Andes it it did specie
8 but not in any rate that was different
from the background rate of speciation
in other geographic regions this is one
of the classic papers and a really
important paper in sort of explosive
diversification patterns in the Andes
this isn't and the genus Lu pinus in the
lupins and here you can see the
geographic distribution of these lupins
and as soon as they hit the Andes
represented in orange you see very very
short branch lengths and lots of species
similar to that inga tree so a very
recent explosive pile of genetic
diversification accompanied by
incredible diversification at the
morphological level
so these are some of the some of the
plants that evolved during that
radiation so including everything from
herbaceous to to trees this is all
evolved within a quaternary time scale
some of the fastest diversification ramp
rates that were measured for plants or
animals were published in that paper so
when we look at we pull out all of them
all the sequences from GenBank for the
lupins from all over the world we put
them in a phylogenetic tree we can see
that across all lupins there are some
areas and some of this might be affected
by sample size as well that are slower
slower evolving or more quickly evolving
and here we have our Andean group right
here but you can see that there's really
no evidence for any significant rate
change lupins evolve very rapidly in the
Andes that they were already evolving
very rapidly in the Rocky Mountains
already evolving very rapidly in the
Mexican mountains and when they were in
the Andes they just continue to evolve
very rapidly and in all fairness the
authors do recognize that in the
subsequent paper so this is just a
general pattern of lupine biology not
necessarily something that's specific to
the Andes
draba is a is a group that does show a
strong signature of Andy and
diversification so compared to all the
taxes that are outside of the antes when
it hits the antes its it has a
significantly increased rate of
diversification Tezuka this is another
one that shows a strong signature of
Andy and diversification but you also
see that it shows a significant slowdown
so it diversified initially very quickly
compared to the rest of the clade of
his-- - ca' but then diversification
rates slowed down and so this would
indicate to me that potentially this is
a group that diversified initially as
these plants came into the novel habitat
but they weren't necessarily affected by
the climatic fluctuations of a place to
see valeriano shows a similar pattern
where it showed a significant increase
in diversification initially followed by
a slow down to the present
so the initial results of the
meta-analysis that there's quite a lot
of variability some groups come in they
speak CA to some degree not any
different from the background level of
speciation some groups come in and show
real rampant radiations some of them
show radiations and then stasis over
coming into more recent timescales
indicating that probably my hypothesis
is that they're diversifying initially
as they reach these new habitats but
they're not terribly impacted by
Pleistocene climate changes so the
future works my colleague Steven Smith's
really interested in incorporating it's
much data ecological data as is possible
into these analyses including bio
Geographic data so we want to look at
excuse me
the ecological correlates of these rate
increases we would like to also do more
transcriptomic work we want to look at
the genus clue Xia which is in the clues
EAC this is one of the only tree
lineages that has Cam photosynthesis
which allows it to photosynthesize in
very dry periods it has a combination of
c3 and cam photosynthesis and this is a
genus that shows high levels of species
turnover as you move up slopes in the
Andes and so we're interested looking at
the evolution of that photosynthetic
mechanism and how some of these may have
impacted evolutionary divergence is
within the Andes and we're also
interested in working with the
geologists to better pull together
geological history with the planned
phylogenetic history in particular
biologists have been working for a long
time thinking that some of the high
elevation habitats like the para mo are
a certain age the maximum 5 million
years but these geologists say that the
ages of the eastern and western
Cordilleras of the Andes are very
different and in the western parts of
the Andes which are sort of a volcanic
origin as opposed to origin by
faulting that these might have a much
deeper history so we want to see if we
can find clades that are much deeper in
age than five million years so I like
particularly thank Steven and Carolyn I
graduated in Jordan in postdoc Ashley
Thompson and my geological GOG now makes
colleagues and I'd be happy to take any
questions
one thing that he was doing I was
developing my life is based on
transcript deferens say they'll take the
transcribed genes
from a number of
and pharmacology meta-analyses
various genetic groups and you give up
the see that there are certain groups
certain genes that are hot buyers are
evolving much more quickly
nice I said that might be one way to
sort of get at with it whether the
actual functions that are all better at
the Baltimore regular there others in
some of these groups that might Kristine
vacation
fat-bellied he went
what bad things like looking at the
living fossil lineages versus the more
dispersal 212 his first municipal recent
changes that they think that definitely
was like in terms of Bonilla for example
well very interested looking below the
surface of the dunya
I find it hard to believe that in such a
biotic challenging environment such as
profitable for us huge amounts of pest
pressure pathogens
insect damage constantly that there
wouldn't get a lot of evolution
happening but they have to do its
secondary defense or other trade we're
just not
I think that was very
the last few examples represent
embarrass my students
relative rate changes and speciation
events I was wondering if there is a
higher level pattern with a Kristin
woody came and they fall out into these
categories
that's a really good question and
everyone you look at that
these are just the initial
so they're on the same scale
yeah I'm not sure if some of that is
groups is there somebody else is there
that measure that applied to be
reflector investigation station
but their generation
this is a more general it may be a nice
question about the species
diversification but after something like
a long-distance disconnection dispersal
thank you
you know you might expect that species
to like diversify when it finds new
ecosystem but they also see a tropic
species diversity that were of species
that were already there sort of like the
species that is coming from far away it
is an invasive and how does that impact
because the Senate moves to wipe it down
there aren't many cases where we have
long distances first moment where as
pieces of
and already species rich environment and
universalize I think in case of the
Andean region I think a lot of tax are
riding there and then entering in an
occupied space as they're able to
diversify just
without too much competition and at some
point there may be a point where there's
been too much space there's a certain
cherry
they did this personal event that I
mentioned early
apart from the Indian colonization or it
never much nation capital office
facility or based on traffic so that you
calibrate the methanol
so this meta-analysis don't have any
kind of time calibration on them said
they're just looking at a skater based
on the numbers of those sort of the
relative place so they don't really they
don't really try to put the agent on
this and probably wouldn't trust
they just showered and there's the
recently
mmm in its also yes some of these
methods are dependent on technology
please
there are many limitations
but if Isis
among the more decently diversifying
species they stay crossed hybridized and
produced hybrid progeny I'm only very
familiar with Ginga and those species to
my knowledge are very
morphologically distinct and without too
many intermediates and they also tend to
have widespread overlapping
distributions so speciated in small
isolated valleys and haven't had contact
it's not how they manage to sneeze gate
and then develop reproductive barriers
to develop overlapping distributions for
the other groups of the bees
we have a population that's why because
we didn't have it to roughly like the
Andes help you can you rule out
dispersal over the Andes the
similarities between two components
yeah that part of the main protection is
they protect Peter a sort of this is a
sort of like hearing a narrative where
the ends justify in the populations for
the alternative hypothesis is sometimes
and will be nice to do to get enough tax
and to just determine
there are some relatively low areas in
the enemy's 2,000 meters where
conceivably
whatever periods of time
there also benefit dispersal in any sort
of what is now be honest sort of along
the slopes of the mountains there other
possibilities and also like in the case
of sentience atha has been around
deported before the
and said that that's always an
alternative this personal versus
backwards then I think it'd be difficult
for them to get over the Andes the best
part is a real strong
what happens when you start nesting
species which other income higher tax in
your
there is TV funny that let's say a
family member and some faculties are
prone to grab the diversification
misogynist
because this always that idea Nativity
is there something intrinsic to a clades
genomics attention to morphological
diversity I'm starting to think that
about latest about that they've got that
later
predominant every trees in the rain
horse around the world
so there might be something there might
be certain bruising
biology or surprises surveyors
but the death mystical has played reason
well surprise the ugly word Natalia
community
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu